until yesterday there were at least
three Americans unlawfully detained in
Russia Paul Wellen a former Marine
arrested on Espionage charges Mark Fogle
a 61 year old history teacher arrested
for possessing a small amount of medical
marijuana and Brittany Greiner a young
anti-American lady basketball player
arrested for the same crime for the the
marijuana
two of those people are still stuck
doing hard labor in Russia one gets to
go home can you guess which one Britney
is uh is an incomparable athlete a
two-time Olympic gold medalist for Team
USA she endured mistreatment and has
showed attitude in a show trial in
Russia with characteristic grit and
incredible dignity
she represents the best America
the best about America it is across the
board everything about her
the best about America just across the
board Brittany Greiner the lady
basketball player whose only noteworthy
activity is to date have been playing a
sport that no one watches protesting the
Star-Spangled Banner at that sport
refusing to show up on the court for the
national anthem and trying to sneak pot
into Russia Brittany Greiner represents
the best the very best of America
apparently not the history teacher not
the Marine the dope smoking
america-hating WNBA person whose release
the US was so desperate to secure that
it agreed to release the world's most
notorious arms dealer back to Russia in
exchange too bad for the Marine too bad
for the history teacher but the pot
smoking basketball lady who hates the
Star-Spangled Banner she gets to go home
who are those people the one who's
getting the most play right now is Paul
Wellen he is this Marine who actually
spoke with CNN by phone uh around this
release of Brittany Greiner basically
saying hey guys hey Biden uh you mind
what what gives man
they've always considered me to be at a
higher level than other criminals
um of my sort and
um for whatever reason I'm treated
differently than another
um individual here from a western
country that's also on a charge of
espionage
so even though we're both here for
Espionage I'm treated much differently
than he is and my treatment is also much
different than others held for Espionage
at other presents I would say that if a
message could quote a President Biden
that um
you know this is a precarious situation
that needs to be resolved quickly and I
would hope that he and his
administration would do everything they
could to get me home
regardless of the price they might have
to pay at this point
so the guy's desperate he's been in in a
Russian prison now for four years I
think it is unlike Brittany Greiner who
was there for about nine ten months and
he's saying guys you really got to get
me out of here and he says I'm being
treated differently than the other
prisoners he's here in charge of
Espionage the reaction from everybody
demanding his release has been to laugh
this at this charge of Espionage and say
this is totally trumped up nonsense from
Vladimir Putin to use a political Pawn
to but I actually don't know I mean
maybe the guy's a spy I think I think to
make a stronger argument for his release
we should take seriously the possibility
that he's a spy he's got a military
background he went in and out of Russia
a whole lot of times in the last few
years he apparently had contacts at the
FSB so which is the Russian security
service
so let's just say for a second that he's
a spy and I'm I'm not
I'm not declaring that he is I don't
know there's also a lot of evidence that
he was not a spy the CIA denies that
Paul Wellen was a spy because his
military record was pretty spotty and
the agency is saying nobody who had all
this kind of terrible conduct in the
military and who was demoted and had all
these issues no nobody uh of with that
kind of a background would be hired as a
spy by the CIA I don't know I mean I I
can see why Russians might be under the
impression that the guy is a spy but but
my point is let's say that he is a spy
let's say that this guy is James
freaking Bond
and he's very very high value
we just gave up a guy who's also
extremely high value we just the guy
that we just gave up is known as The
Merchant of death okay the guy that we
just gave up Victor boot is the most
notorious arms dealer in the world
Russia really really really wanted to
secure this guy's release
and and so let's say Paul Wellen is is
the biggest super spy in the history of
the world Joe Biden still should have
secured his release we gave up a really
really big Russian asset in exchange for
what
a lady basketball player who was
opportunistically taken hostage by by
the Russians as a pawn because of this
issue right now over the war in Ukraine
and because the United States was was
putting all of these sanctions on Russia
and because Russia wanted some leverage
okay I don't even like Brittany Greiner
okay but you
hit her detainment had a political
aspect too yes she violated the laws of
Russia yes Russia has the right to its
own drug laws no I don't really have all
that much sympathy with Brittany Greiner
trying to sneak drugs into Russia but
obviously this detainment was political
obviously it was pretty flimsy and so
what kind of deal does Joe Biden make
the only makes is will will give you a
very very very high value Asset that has
done very very very bad things and you
can be very valuable to Russia in
exchange for
this lady basketball player but you can
keep our marine you can keep our history
teacher it's just just on its face even
even if you believe all of the Russian
charges against these two Americans who
remain detained it's just a terrible
terrible deal I know what you're
thinking Michael you Adonis you just
hunk of beautiful manhood how do you
stay looking so fresh and young and sexy
let's just call it like it is well my
friends I'm here to tell you about
genucel skin care I love these guys I
totally trust these guys I'm very
skeptical of a lot of products designed
to keep you looking good and looking
healthy and vibrant I am not skeptical
of genucel skin care I absolutely adore
this product now for Christmas
geniuselle's most popular package is 70
off this includes two months worth of
geniusell's best sellers plus their
hyaluronic acid serum for free with your
purchase I in particular listen I don't
sleep the only things I ever drink are
black coffee and tea and occasionally
some adult beverages I smoke cigars I
stay up late my under eye bags need all
the help that they can get genius out as
a marvelous product for that and so much
else geniusell uses a proprietary base
with clinical levels of Botanical
extracts which come together to yield
amazing results right now go to
genucell.com Knowles use code Knowles
for an additional 10 off your order plus
every order is instantly upgraded to
free express shipping that is
geniusell.com Knowles kwles
geniusell.com
Knowles the guy they got is
cartoonishly villainous take a listen
this was up from a 60 Minutes interview
over who Victor boot is
Victor booed uh in in my eyes
um is one of the most dangerous men on
the face of the Earth on the face of the
Earth without a doubt
Mike Braun the former Chief of
operations for the U.S Drug Enforcement
Administration told us boot first
exploded on the scene in war-torn West
Africa in the late 1980s
elevating bloody conflicts from machetes
and single shot rifles to
AK-47s not by the thousands but by the
tens of thousands so he weaponizes Civil
War in Africa he transformed these young
adolescent Warriors into
Insidious mindless maniacally driven
killing machines that operated with
assembly line efficiencies now 43 boot
from the Soviet Republic of Tajikistan
is a mystery man who reportedly served
in the Soviet Air Force and intelligence
service
the U.S has indicted him on four
terror-related charges including
conspiracy to kill Americans
so not a great guy you know kind of a
bad ombre and they make this trade why
did the White House make this trade we
all know why
the White House made this trade because
Brittany Greiner is a a liberal black
lesbian that's why and in fact the White
House basically admitted as much in the
the big announcement you had Kareem
Jean-Pierre talking about how important
this is espec not for only for all
Americans but especially for the LGBT
LMNOP community and it's so so important
that we get this lady back and Biden was
always going to cut any deal that he
could to get her back not because of any
particular National interest in bringing
this lady back over other detained
Americans but because it looks really
good to the Democrat base and because
it's very very politically correct and
the important part here is that Vladimir
Putin knew that the Russians knew that
too
you would not have seen this kind of a
deal this kind of a week week deal under
Donald Trump but Putin knew that they
would get it under Joe Biden because the
right the Russians have always been very
good at understanding the fault lines in
American politics on Race on sex on
everything and and so they knew that
they would get it and they they got they
they just ripped us off okay
if it had been
okay we released the you the Arms Dealer
and they released Brittany Greiner and
Paul Wellen or and Paul Wellen and Mark
Vogel or something like that that would
have been one thing but that's not what
we got
not what we got at all and so we had the
handoff here and the funniest part about
the handoff is you get the two planes
landing in Abu Dhabi
and you get the the guys walking up with
Victor boot
and you get the actually just one guy
walking up with Victor boot I mean he's
a pretty tough ombre he can handle
himself then you get multiple guys
walking up with Brittany Greiner and
then
they're sort of shaking hands there on
the tarmac you see with the guy and then
there's a film cut
so you see Victor booty shakes hands
with one of his handlers shakes hands
with another Handler and then he kind of
leans and and then there's this cut and
it occurred to me
they cut the footage of when Brittany
Greiner shakes hands with the notorious
Russian arms dealer known as The
Merchant of death
as I said you know that really messes up
our image here that's that's really
going to play into conservatives hands
if they already don't have a
particularly high opinion of this lady
because the only thing she's known for
is getting detained by the Russians and
disrespecting America and then healing
and use your shaking hands with a guy
known as The Merchant of death so even
that they bungle it it's just an
absolute embarrassment another
embarrassment
for Joe Biden and for the United States
very very frustrating this is fake
headline Friday I need your help
to uh help me beat Ben Davies he has
given me four real headlines one fake
headline I need you to help me get this
headline correct so head on over right
now if you're not a member click the
link in the description and join us
[Music]
foreign